are you suffering death by a million
paper cuts hopefully not because that
sounds awful but if that's a metaphor
for your small file uploads messing with
your performance then you're in luck
today on cloud storage bytes we're
diving deep into the world of optimizing
your small file uploads so stick around
let's say you're a biotech company and
your main product is a software that
works with DNA across multiple
distributed machines everything is great
but whenever you add a data set your
clients are stuck waiting and waiting to
begin computation you've checked your
architecture and it's pretty
straightforward a new data set comes in
gets divided and uploaded a cloud
storage triggering a pub/sub alert for
your clients to start computing so
what's the problem here
this is the tricky bit the amount of
work each client is responsible for
changes depending on the number of
clients connected to do work so having
more clients leads to smaller work
blocks as the clients balance out that
workload this means that your software
will take ages to upload all the files
to Google Cloud storage in regions with
the highest number of available cores so
let's say you've got a data set with
files of various sizes and you upload
each file to a regional bucket over and
over and over again if you were to take
a look under the hood while this upload
takes place you'd see that as file size
increases so does the throughput speed
meaning smaller files are gonna bog you
down like a death by a million paper
cuts which once again sounds rough the
reason for smaller files slowing things
down is because of the amount of
transactional overhead for uploading
those files the smaller each individual
file is the more times this
transactional overhead adds up and gives
you issues there's good news here and
that comes by way of parallel uploads as
we hinted at in an earlier episode you
can use the - M option in gsutil to
perform a parallel copy and dramatically
increase the performance of your uploads
if you were to revisit your example of
the data set from earlier and take
another peek right under the hood this
time using parallel uploads you'd see
significantly higher throughput as that
pesky transactional overhead is
mitigated across the multiple parallel
threads problem solved and paper cuts
avoided but how does this help with
large file uploads we have answers but
that's a totally different episode if
you want to know more about parallel
uploads for small files check out the
link in the
description and don't forget to
subscribe give us a like and tell us
what more you want to learn about Google
Cloud storage thank you for joining us
for this quick byte of cloud storage see
you next time
[Music]